Speaker 1: All right. I have incredibly good news
and incredibly bad news about the children's book
I wrote about critical thinking. You know, I joked
last week, if someone tries to ban this book,
it might actually be a great thing. We now we're
up against the first attempt to ban the book,
and it's from a school library. I'll tell
you about it in a moment. So here is the
good of the book. And of course, here is
the copy of the book, and it's fantastic.
You can find it at David Packman dot com slash
book. A lot of really good things. Number one,
4200 copies have been ordered so far. That's
3800 paperbacks and about 400 Kindle copies.
It seems with this book, about 90% of people want
the physical book for the kids. 4200 copies to 12
different countries. When we did this, I thought
it would be a success if the book ever sold 500
copies. We're five days in and we've sold 4200
copies. Incredible Number one Amazon bestseller
in multiple categories, including children's
school and education books. This is the number
one book on Amazon for children's school and
education books. I don't even know what I'm
doing to quote the failed former president. That's
all great. We're working on getting the book on
Barnes and Noble. It's not up to us. Barnes Noble
is announcing a major delay in approving any new
authors for self-publishing. I can't control it.
As soon as Barnes and Noble, let's assign it will
be available there. We're constantly releasing
because we can tweak the manuscript at any time.
We're constantly making little tweaks and finding
small things to correct or improve. It's the same
book. It'll just get a little more sophisticated
over time. But here's the bad. We are now seeing
the first attempt to ban it. I heard from a I
can't tell if it's I guess it is a librarian or
a library employee at a school in North Carolina.
Okay. She's asking to be identified only as book.
I like that. She says the following. Hey, David.
I work in the school library in North Carolina
in a part of the state that's more liberal. But
we have lots of conservative parents from the
surrounding rural areas who bring their kids to
school. I regularly buy new books for the library,
and for the first week we put them in a new
book section near the front door. I got a copy
of your book and regularly see kids looking
at it. I saw the I guess this means mothers.
It's a there's a typo here, but I believe it means
the mothers of two kids page through it, whisper
to each other and then tell me they want to file a
complaint about the book. Our school, thankfully,
hasn't been overrun by the MAGA crazies, so there
really isn't even a complaint process for books.
So I told them to talk to the principal or
superintendent. They were indignant, saying,
You can just get whatever books you want as the
librarian. I explained that as the librarian,
That is part of my job ordering books. I haven't
heard anything since. But I will let you know what
happens. Please keep my name private and don't
mention the school. But you can call me bookie in
North Carolina. Keep up the great work. Okay. She
actually didn't even mention her real name, nor
nor what school this is going on at. So listen.
Somebody didn't like something. And, you know,
I got a couple complaints from people saying.
David, the kid that looks like Trump in the
book. It's it politicizes the book. And now this
is this is the picture of the kid that looks like
Trump. You shouldn't have done that, folks. You
all know who I am. You all know my show. This is
it's just it's just a picture of a kid that looks
like Trump. It's part of the thing. If it angers
conservatives, then so be it. Trump lies about
crowd sizes all the time. That's the kind of joke
that's told in the book. It's really not a big
deal. Let's all relax so you can get the book at
David Packman dot com slash book. Very important.
Please leave a review. We've sold 4200 copies and
there's only 80 reviews. If we could get three,
four or 500 reviews. It would just blow the
book up because so much of the recommendations
algorithm is based on reviews. So forget about
if you've already bought the book, you. That's
great. Thank you. Please make sure if you bought
the book that you review the book. Really
important. David Packman, dot com slash book